the queue outside this little bakery in
Sudan's capital Khartoum means there's
more pressure on safe a dingus Malang
the Baker says flour isn't as caused as
it was nine months ago so people don't
expect a shortage but because of other
reasons there is a shortage visualized
there is a shortage of fuel and we don't
know why it has resulted in a shortage
of bread produced we have had to cut
back on bread we bake and sell bread
shortage in December as part of protests
that quickly became a nationwide call
for the country's longtime President
Omar al-bashir to step down he was
deposed by the military in April after
months of demonstrations the military
and protest leaders have now agreed to
form a transitional government a final
power sharing agreement was signed on
Saturday after months of talks paving
way for what many Sudanese hope will be
a new start but the upcoming
transitional government has 39 months to
function as per the deal and many issues
to tackle before elections are held at
the end of its term our first demand
that we have for the transitional
government is accountability for all
those who did wrong to the people of
this country no one should be above
accountability and there should be a
free and fair Judah Kerry to deliver
justice a lot needs to be done the
government needs to work on delivering
health care and education the economy is
important because we're suffering we
can't get food or transport easily we
want better services and those are just
among the many issues facing people here
the transitional government will have to
deal with the various conflicts around
the country and the armed groups raging
them some of those groups who are also
part of the opposition coalition have
rejected the agreement it will need to
work on Sudan's permanent Constitution
as well and hold elections all in a
government that shares powers between
the military and civilians
the talks to form the transitional
government weren't always smooth they
broke down several times before the deal
was reached some analysts say how the
two sides work in their partnership will
have an impact not just within the
country but in its relations with other
countries the profits mr. diamond has a
hill climber and yet team Sudan is on
the US list of state-sponsored terrorism
and to lift it a lot of issues need to
be resolved with regards to internal
politics like the issues of war and
peace in the country the main problem
between the two sides who big in issues
related to conflict and security with
the deal signed many like safe will be
looking to see what changes come vary
Sudan is now a nation waiting to see if
its new government will be able to
fulfill the demands of millions of its
citizens Heba Morgan all Jazeera
Khartoum